this video is going to be about
visualization or is sometimes referred
to in a sports sense as a mental
rehearsal
so our practices like this are still
viewed as a little bit kind of weird a
bit whoo and a bit kind of esoteric if
you will which i think is a real shame
because the mind-body connections are
really fascinating topic and the strong
evidence that using practices like
visualization are really really useful
tool to help you improve now my content
is primarily martial arts related as you
know however I think this is a concept
that is applicable to any kind of skill
that you wish to develop so whether or
not you're a practicing martial artist
or not try to view these concepts
through the lens of your own chosen
discipline and then you know like apply
them from that point visualization is
the process of basically using your
imagination to mentally perform a task
as opposed to actually physically train
in it the most popular theory to do with
this is the psycho neuromuscular theory
according to this the sub-threshold
activation of muscles during a mental
rehearsal session are very close to that
of the actual same skill performed
physically simply put the brain
struggles to differentiate between an
action real and imagined and this is the
basis of what is sometimes known as
subconscious programming so a famous
study with college basketball students
illustrates the power of this putz is
quite considerably the students were
split into three groups and they were
each tested on how many free throws that
they could make the first group
practiced actual free throws every day
for one hour the second group only
visualized himself making the free
throws with no physical practice and the
third group just did nothing at all
after 30 days they were tested once
again the first group who were engaging
in the physical practice improved by 24%
the third group who did nothing didn't
improve at all which was obviously to be
expected however the second group who
engaged in only mental practice improved
by 23% without even touching a
basketball even though this can be
beneficial from anybody from a complete
beginner to an expert there are some
factors that determine the effectiveness
of the practice and those are the
expertise level of the participant the
retention interval between practice and
performance of the skill and also the
length of the mental rehearsal session
okay and I'm going to give you a few
basic instructions on how to do this
technique you need to set an intention
beforehand so that you know what to
focus on during your practice next you
want to find a place where you won't be
disturbed and sit into a comfortable
chair then close your eyes to block out
any distractions from your immediate
environment and turn your attention
inward we're going to breathe in through
the nose and slowly out through the
mouth
until we relax ourselves into what is
known as an alpha brainwave state alpha
is the doorway to the subcon
and you know you're in that brainwave
state when you begin to feel relaxed and
have less of a focus on your current
surroundings once you begin to feel that
you are sufficiently relaxed then begin
visualizing yourself in first person
performing whatever sequence or movement
that you want and just keep repeating
that over and over again throughout your
visualization practice try to really
internalize how it would feel as you
visualize to build on those
neuromuscular connections can you feel
the ground under your feet as you move
how about the clothes moving against
your skin and so on is particularly
effective to do this practice as you
drift enough to sleep or waking up in
the morning as we are approaching or
leaving a deep sleep or Delta brainwave
state will naturally pass through the
desired alpha state meaning that some of
the relaxation work will be already
taken care of for you this should be
practiced from anywhere between ten and
thirty minutes
now just before we advance to the next
section I just want to show you this
clip of Conor McGregor defeating Jose
Aldo for the UFC featherweight title
back in 2015 now check out this clip of
him warming up in this locker room
before the fight practice in the exact
same shot that he used to win the fight
and then see the two side-by-side very
cool you can see it here and you have
the courage enough to speak it it will
happen so I see these shots I see these
sequences and I don't shy away from them
this comment from one of my previous
videos really resonated with me when you
watch a video of someone do martial arts
your mirror neurons trigger and without
realizing it your mind and body is
actually training while you watch the
video I think visualization also helps
trigger your mirror neurons as if you
were training the reason it resonated
was that recently I had become aware
that had kind of been practicing a form
of visualization when I was a kid in the
form of watching clips of martial
artists I admired over and over again
and then going out and literally feeling
like I could move like those people and
using my creative imagination even
though I couldn't actually physically do
that yet it didn't really matter I was
just having fun with it like kids do
using their imagination however therein
lies one of the major keys to an
effective visualization especially in
ambition in future circumstances that
you want to work towards and that's
saturating the images with this much
positive emotion as you can and not
letting your inner critic creep into
your mind and tell you that it's not
possible I believe the reason I was able
to do this quite effectively is children
are not yet conditioned
by the norms and limitations of society
that they then receive as they grow up
and therefore they believe anything is
possible meaning that I was able to
practice this relatively free of
self-doubt which is generally the
strongest factor that hinders the
majority of adults and Bunnell to do
something that they want to do now
obviously the majority of the audience
here are not children however if you're
able to remain aware enough to know that
your mind is inevitably going to try to
throw you off with learn limitations and
beliefs whenever you're trying to change
something then that can be enough to
stop you identifying with those thoughts
be vigilant and continue on with
confidence now there's another layer to
this as well it is also paramount to
understand and that's the difference
between the conscious and the
subconscious mind and how this relates
to visualization practice this image
serves as a metaphor for how our minds
work in simple terms the conscious mind
is the only part that we can affect at
anytime and are aware of hence its name
the subconscious mind contains much
greater power but cannot be accessed in
the same way as the conscious mind and
is hidden under the surface of our
awareness if you will they'll notice on
the image that the portion of the
subconscious mind contains our beliefs
and habits which are paramount in
achieving any worthy ideal I'll explain
a little about this now but if you would
like to learn more then perhaps the best
book on the topic is psycho cybernetics
by dr. Maxwell Maltz this book was
originally written in the 1960s however
it's still an incredible resource today
and is still on the recommended reading
list of many many highly successful
people 90% of the men and women alive
today have an image of themselves as
distorted as the reflection in a
funhouse mirror
the first and basic truth of cybernetic
image is all boats uses the analogy that
we are like a thermostat in our homes
you set the thermostat for a certain
temperature and then any deviation from
that causes the thermostat to kick in
and bring the temperature up or down to
its setpoint are subconsciously held
beliefs
I like that setpoint on the thermostat
so take for instance the belief that you
are a healthy person you might see
yourself as somebody who goes to the gym
regularly who eats well and who takes
care of themself however maybe you go on
vacation and you eat a little bit too
much and you know gain some extra body
fat then your subconscious beliefs will
kick in automatically and you'll begin
to feel strange you won't feel like
yourself and then you'll begin to
automatically find yourself moving
towards making the changes until you're
back
at the set point that you feel
comfortable with this example is easy to
understand when we hold a positive image
of ourselves however what's almost more
important to understand is the same is
true if we hold a negative image of
ourselves the subconscious is not known
to differentiate between positive and
negative feedback so if you hold a
subconscious negative image of yourself
whether that's physically or with
regards to your potential for instance
then no matter how much you try to force
change consciously you're always gonna
find yourself back at that same place
sooner or later this is often referred
to as the snapback effect
so imagine stretching out an elastic
band that's wrapped around your finger
the band is eventually going to reach
its breaking point and snap back to its
original position
in my own experience this can be a very
tricky thing to remain aware of because
those negative beliefs will almost kind
of hold you in a way and they will take
on the form of things that feel very
real to you in the moment and very
rational be aware that they will come up
and remain vigilant as you moving
forwards I think that to only view this
in terms of rehearsing a physical
movement for a sport for instance is
doing a little bit of an injustice to
the potential of this kind of work we
can use this in all different areas of
our lives to improve things that were
not really that happy with there are
many different schools of thought on
this topic as you know that we've been
talking about sports science may call
this mental rehearsal and the New Age
community may call it manifesting or the
law of attraction but if you look at it
from a broad scale and pass the dogma
then you realize that a lot of what's
been said by these groups is actually
the same thing under different names
psycho-cybernetics hits the nail on the
head with its premise of once difficult
now easy as mentioned previously our
subconscious minds can't be accessed in
the same way as our conscious minds in
our regular everyday thinking it only
responds to certain known stimuli and
even then there are very few of those
that we actually have any control over
so they are one repetition number two
traumatic events
number three authority figures and the
before hypnosis so the one that we
obviously want to exploit with this
visualization practice is repetition
remember the subconscious mind is where
habits are formed so it's really quite a
good job we have to repeat what we want
to learn otherwise everything we did
including terrible mistakes would
automatically become habitual
so in knowing that the subconscious mind
needs to receive the message again and
again over time until it begins to build
a new habit should hopefully help you to
ease up a little and not become
discouraged when you don't see immediate
changes if you find that you struggle to
form solid images or constant
trait during a visualization session and
can't really get into the flow then
another very good book that offers a
progressive visualization course is the
master key system by Charles Hanul it's
actually a very old book so some of the
language is a little bit outdated but if
you can see past that it's really quite
a practical resource the actor Terry
Crews credits this book with helping him
achieve your success and supposedly Bill
Gates as well although it hasn't been
recorded anywhere when I got this book
called the master key system it broke
down some things in ways that I can
understand and one of the concepts in
the book is that in order to have you
have to do in order to do you have to be
with fitness you are fit before your
body ever gets in shape you have to be
business I hope you use the information
in this video as a tool to improve in
something you want be that a physical
skill or a circumstance that you wish to
bring about into your life
there really are the same thing if you
look from a broaden of perspective and
finally to quote Bruce Lee guys remember
not to mistake the finger for the moon
understand that being inspired by
somebody doesn't mean that you want to
just completely copy and emulate that
person it means that there's qualities
about them that excite you and then it's
identifying those qualities and working
out how to apply them to your own life
to become more of yourself and your true
essence thank you very much for watching
if you liked this video and found value
in it please subscribe to the Baniya and
follow me across all social media
platforms thank you very much for
watching and I'll see you next time